[Music]
it's that time [__] guys clear out
the old [__] lungs to make passes for
the smoke to go in are you guys doing
it's Tuesday November 22nd hope you guys
are well you're two days away from
eating turkey and getting tryptophan out
of your [__] eyeballs
so the develop that hungry gonna hang
out with Uncle joy for a few hours we
got a great show two feet 11 up my man
Rudy Sarzo my main man and going by
lease I had is here you know us a brand
new contain apeshit and a bag of [__]
stars I'd have to tell you at that time
of this I don't know what plans yet
tonight they [__] me just went kaput
those uncle Joey showed up [__] you
understand but enough with the chitter
chatter it's time to let the pigeons
loose
[Music]
that's a white pitching right days I'm
saying anyway it's a beautiful day to be
alive and the beautiful thing about it
is you've got the world by the boss
there you know that nothing really is
[__] real
we gotta always wait there fulfil this
mother [__] up nicely oh yeah I see
now we got [__] circulation again
it's like I can't smoke dope if I have a
glue me in my [__] neck I'm saying I
gotta clear with that same [__]
difference a five second step it's
paying this off it was spring cleaning
in here
that's [__] carbon I got two pounds
of weed on the [__] floor plus it's
acid mushroom dust chlamydia powder
I got [__] the fungi toenail Buster
Falls and sprinkles around we got a lot
of [__] on the floor here yeah I'm
saying but what does that mean that
means we're doing our [__] job okay
and you got a clean floor you better
reevaluate your [__] Brown
[Music]
those that blimp - always gets the blood
going you know I'm saying let's stretch
out a little bit here the [__] wall
crunch stuff on top of you [__] like
[__] something matters
don't get no better than that well don't
miss Berlin that's a [__] looking
years old and somebody coming in that
sack at the same time singing [__] a
song I'm saying that that happened I
don't know no midgets anyway did you say
stop that's what I was thinking - still
in the afternoon but he does a [__] okay
I'm not gonna live a [__] lie and
tell you if you ain't high by two
o'clock you know what
and anyone worth having your periscope I
hope periscope Kansas you five-second
goes back to a level a [__] cable
[Music]
well Joe it's a holy week with holy
pilgrims the [__] Protestants my
check time sucker is how we doing today
it's gonna be a mouth afternoon and
aperitif as we quality the business 200
milligrams
the power of Christ come with the purple
oh yeah now we do it Doug would you like
a sing-along [__] an edible star
either long you know planning just a
makes it good nice and festive if I tell
ya the apology you put a fucked-up face
on Joey it's too early yeah but if you
like this I just wanna through the time
all right
oh yeah we're not even chewing I'm gonna
let my intestines do the job today
that's 5,000 milligrams at two o'clock a
thousand at two o'clock that's it we
dance get crazy we call for the 8-ball
you know we do it in we don't play cake
Thanksgiving Day gobble gobble where the
[__] you at stuff in some [__] airport
but my aunt needs me you're at whoever
sent that [__]
at the beautiful moorhead little writing
i met my friend Becky went got some
Cuban food for Rudy leave myself my wife
Alicia Michaels it's a birthday if you
see him or she's on Twitter or Facebook
say Felicia happy birthday you
[__] if you're eating edibles you
got a team do me a favor hang up now I
don't want no drama with Grandma where
have I you stole their [__] arthritis
pills you don't need the aggravation of
my life I have my own [__] problem
don't forget December 8th uncle Joey
Diaz is first special
[Music]
socially unacceptable right see so TV
this is how you gotta watch it's not
gonna cost you a [__] dime you're
gonna go to see so TV and you're gonna
press in code Joey and they're gonna
give you too much for free you know why
cuz leave those people to happy the CEO
is Jewish I'm saying don't forget
tomorrow night let the [__] air my
name probably Steve Simone myself with
the rest of those [__] stars well you
don't worry under Eggman let's go meet
my college buddies about the future of
millenials get the [__] out of my face
everybody wants company on Thanksgiving
you know I'm saying you gonna sit there
with a bunch of old people you thankful
for my legs get the [__] out of here I'm
thankful for that [__] piece si got
last night another 44th Street Amsterdam
not me I'm an old man I get no ass no
more
I just think about it you go what the
[__] that I do it my life 20 years wait
point be understanding anyway excuse me
excuse me I feel it
I was a little [__] [__] smoke then
I'll even bother with that lis ready
move over there change some music you
and get into a better this is like the
[__] companion out how you guys doing
today he's probably thinking about
travel or whatever [__] you gonna do
don't let me forget to take next
tutorial script on please excuse for
mentioning I think he wrote this some
[__] pencil this is what I got deal
with people people giving you scripts
read it do you want to be in and listen
do I look like I want to be in [__]
some look at my face I don't have been
nothing right I just wanna be left to
[__] alone I want do my podcast with my
little [__] friend over here Johnny
zipline this is the cops are coming in
where they tell you it ain't me people
be trying to finish it on me since day
one
don't get me wrong well that was a kid I
was a [__] burglar to have I had
sticky fingers for the sticky fingers
you know I'm saying [__] would stick to
my [__] bones if I was dead that's
how good I was back then put my vision
on [__]
I can't see without my glasses people
someday you [__] are gonna get
old you're laughing at me now you didn't
know excited I'll say this a grams from
my [__] ute it's like they got a ball
off the dust I'm back all right
stop complaining get the bun that's all
you gotta do when you see uncle Joey
yeah listen I'm gonna hate by your
problems over here baby personal
problems your social problems you just
get the pipe the bond whatever let's say
you wanna have a wonderful Joey you show
up with a [__] you see Lisa you show up
on an emperor why cause he's Jewish
Jewish people don't like chalk all right
but you're gonna choose how Steven
chocolate flowers you take those flowers
and shove up your [__] ass okay you
gotta show up at a temple a bomb it is
your will attend our savings bond but
you'll take $10 with a smile any data we
can catch you just made this [__] day
next time you go to a Jewish person's
have some show up with food before the
two hundred castle this is one they want
a tuna they go back boys with little
make that they want [__] my Sealy
itself son please that's just Belize
investor please not a bad guy that's
just the way he is
[Music]
then he goes complaining but a bomb hit
him saying thank God he shows up he
shows up with rolling papers and no weed
this cut second I got rolling papers
look at me yeah that's great give me a
bomb I'll smack in the face only they
ain't got eighteen years but they are
collected from flock of them the purge
is a [__] purgatory let's fill this
[__] with those resumes right there you
thought I'd bought leave that you can
see everything of that arrested [__]
THC
people with died across the street
it's a beautiful bundage Lisa and
training he just got his [__] 8th
straight like the acid make the mushroom
schedules every aid that pertains to him
disappear he knew had a his ass
especially they just disappeared
who takes and throws them away when I -
Joel forget we put 22 pounds of
mushrooms there I come back from that is
too little something for male looking
things I think you saw about eBay
what man we do what we do
I'm not gonna come on in and tie it to
this party so that's it that's what
makes me happy everybody wants to know
what's happiness team smoking dope with
bleep listen to music knowing that at 5
o'clock I go home and I get a good with
my fat it's all I got
when in doubt smoke more weed you're
absolutely right
let's learn let me Google Google when in
doubt they can't put you in jail they
come over when you stomp the girls they
give you a blood vessel THC trip into
town they found [__] coke did them I
watched the town that's me that's one of
my favorite [__] movies yeah he does
a good job the chip in that movie a
girlfriend it's a big feat to make she's
got size 14 feet that I don't give a
[__] I'll sniff a toes one by one I
don't give a [__] I don't even like
dirty feet I like chicks a big big feet
you know I like a little dirt on the
heels but anything over a [__] 60
next thing about your world my slippers
when you see a woman's foot and she's
competing with you that's the [__]
problem
[Music]
you bad [__] this day you've
got a second son I love you on my heart
this is Thanksgiving the time you wake
up one morning
what were you mad at whether you hate
this [__] how lucky are we to be [__]
doing this [__] not just the fact that
you got a funk
whether it's an Android iPhone how lucky
you get up every morning and you're not
on the [__] ice is somebody's beaten
to death everything I'll wake up I think
about being in prison and waking up with
another man turning on your [__]
light trying you to get up your piece of
[__] and all that type of stuff so I
know you're feeling bad this time of the
year stop all that [__]
I'm thankful of when you got your help
you have two dollars in the bank who
gives a [__] God gave you another day so
hopefully you'll be [__] Turkey and
that's it that's it yeah and about is
that right or wrong they say if not even
lose your money going to be thankful for
the air you breathe that's it's that
[__] simple
hopefully that air has smoking and I'm
saying if you get nice and [__]
stoners who wants to not be stuck
walking around like a dunce
yeah look at that sign look at the
college son gives a [__] if you smoke
weed you say [__] those colors I got my
own colors in my life so I'm saying
we're gonna start this podcast tomorrow
night Irvine improv don't [__] around
you're gonna [__] around and you're not
gonna be able to get tickets and Joey
then then I told you [__] Tuesday at
2:00
listen we always got a dual boot looks
to [__] let the smoke in the bad
spirits and this [__] world
I was sculpted without golem or
periscope producing less confusion
inside your head
[Music]
all right that's it that's that I hope
you have a [__] phenomenal deck you
to that youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz give
me 15 minutes Rudy Sarzo let's talk
about little music was going on with
Rudy what's going on would leave for the
ziplines company is coming at you
hey I love you [__] righto see
I'll see you before Thursday on
periscope but happy Thanksgiving
[__] drive safely
this is the time of the year will people
get crazier and stay black and will join
us